this could make an enormous difference
for the last few months we know that
scientists not just here in the UK but
around the world
have been looking at the options for
various treatments to covert and so far
there hasn't been much positive news but
this certainly is the first bit of
positive news we're told that this is
the first drug that can actually reduce
mortality so and particularly for those
who are the most sick with coeds so if
you look at people on ventilators this
drug denoxin methadone which is a very
commonly used drug for a number of
different conditions ranging from
arthritis to inflammatory issues to skin
conditions as well this drug can prevent
one death for every eight patients who
are on ventilators who were given it
when you look at people who aren't as
sick as needing ventilators but need
oxygen it can prevent one death for
every 25 patients in that situation so
that's why the NHS is now advising all
hospitals across the UK as of now start
using this as part of the standard
treatment for kovat patients this is all
part of the big recovery trial which is
taking place in the UK it's assessing a
number of different possible treatments
this one opened up for patients and
possible people to use this drug as a
test a while ago and because this drug
is so cheap it only costs five pounds
per dose per patient of this drug and
it's so available as well it was very
easy to find the patients for this so we
know that around 2100 were given the
drug that's compared to 4300 who are
part of the the control group for this
and there were these significant results
and that's why as of today as of
midnight from tonight this drug is now
on the official list of drugs which are
banned for export from the UK such as
the need to get this drug out to those
very sick kovat patients because it has
such a big impact not just here in the
UK but globally as well